when Einstein realized that time elapses
more slowly for an object in motion
compared to the rate which of the lapses
for us here on a stationary clock
he didn't just make a qualitative
statement he made a quantitative
statement he wrote down a formula that
tells us how much more slowly time will
elapse on that moving object and if you
like equations the slowdown formula is 1
over the square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared V is the speed of
the object C is the speed of light but
you don't really like formula let me
show you that equation in action just
through some visual illustrations so
here is a stationary clock with us on
earth here's a clock on a spaceship now
if the ship is not moving the two clocks
tick off time at exactly the same rate
but now let's give that spaceship some
velocity a thousand miles per hour
reasonably quick speed notice that the
slowdown while there is just too small
for us to see it that's why we don't
know about this slowdown at everyday
speeds that we can achieve but let's
take this thousand miles an hour
and kick it up to a much higher velocity
a hundred million miles an hour about
1/6 of the speed of light fast enough to
ground the entire Earth in a single
second there is a slowdown on that clock
if you look really closely kind of
squint you can kind of see it but still
even at this very high speed difficult
to see not a big slowdown so let's kick
up the velocity of the ship even higher
starts bring it to six hundred million
miles an hour the speed of light is
about 670 million miles an hour
now this speed the slowdown of time
becomes obvious right this clock is
ticking off time much slower than our
clock here on earth and just to see it
even more
starkly let's bring that speed of the
ship even higher let's put it at 668
million miles an hour just below the
speed of light and look at how time is
elapsing on the spaceship clock very
slow compared to the rate at which time
elapses on our ordinary clocks here on
earth and this really illustrates quite
wonderfully how we don't know about the
slowdown in our bones intuitively
because we never achieve speeds anywhere
near the speed of light but if routinely
we did travel at speeds near the speed
of light this slowing of time would be
obvious to us this dramatic slowing of
time near the speed of light would be
intuitive it would be in our bones